okay so the first full trailer for
moonlight has just dropped and the new
teaser is filled with easter eggs hidden
details and a lot of things you might
miss throughout this video we're gonna
be breaking down the whole thing and
also mixing in bits of the original
disney plus day trailer as i didn't
cover that when it came out i also know
moonlight is a bit more of an obscure
character as well so we'll be talking
about his origin story in the comics
which will hopefully help you to see why
he's more than just marvel's version of
batman i can't tell the difference
between my week in life
and dreams
[Music]
now we got our first proper look at
moonlight on disney plus day and in it
we were introduced to mark spector who's
going to be played by oscar isaac isaac
is also playing spider-man 2099 in the
upcoming across the spider-verse movie
and i think he's going to be perfect for
both of them i'm going to be breaking
down his character first but if you want
to skip ahead to the part where we focus
solely on the trailer then timecodes
will be linked below first introduced in
werewolf by knight 32 moon knight made
his debut in 1975 created by doug moenke
and don perlin moon knight was
originally supposed to be a villain for
werewolf by night but they quickly saw
his potential as a hero too spectra of
course also means ghost and the
character is supposed to appear similar
to one of these in his white costumes
several of which will be appearing in
the series now throughout the trailer
he's referred to as steven at several
points which is actually one of his
other personalities with mark being the
main one it looks like he works for a
museum but we do get flashes of mark
specter's life at points and he is
contacted by a mysterious person now
spector was born the son of a jewish
rabbi but the pair had a strained
relationship as mark believed that his
dad was a coward because he fled the
east in order to escape the holocaust
mark stated that he should have remained
in fort and this led to him taking
boxing lessons before he switched his
attention to the us marine corps mark
took to it like kevin's spoilers took to
spoiling harry potter and he ended up
joining with force recon which is one of
the us's most famous reconnaissance
groups he also worked in the cia and
this led to him being an expert at
several things now mark's true hero
origin story thingamajig comes when he
stumbles across an archaeological dig in
the middle of egypt here the ancient
temple for the egyptian god of the moon
konshu had been on earth and after
specter was beaten badly by a man named
raul bushman he was left for dead at the
site found by the locals that worshiped
the moon guard he was placed at the feet
of the statue and the guard appeared and
offered him a deal in exchange for
another chance at life he would become
an avatar for consu and the rest is
history wrapped in the selfish shroud of
the god he then became moon knight after
beating bushmen he then returned to
america and became a crime-fighting
vigilante in the marvel universe he also
ended up investing the money that he
made as a mercenary and quickly became a
millionaire which allowed him to spend
his cash on hundreds of funko pops as
well as an arsenal of gadgets these
included things like his projectiles and
moon rangs which
yeah he's not just a batman rip off yet
bear with me now mark has several
personalities which we also see him
possessing in the trailer alongside the
main one we also have the identity
stephen grant which he uses for business
dealings and this is somewhat of a
playboy persona so sort of a bruce no
it's not a bruce it's not bruce wayne i
swear now there's also jake luckily he
works as a taxi driver in the city of
chicago and this allows him to keep his
ear close to the street now being in the
military and also cia mark has killed a
lot of people but at one point in the
comics he did vow to never take another
life this is disney we're dealing with
as well so yeah i can see it being the
same thing here now if you still haven't
subscribed to the channel then this is
our overly annoying reminder that we do
videos like this just about every day
and we'd love to have you as part of the
family we're hoping to hit the million
mark by the end of 2022 and it would be
awesome to have you on board we're also
giving away some marvel box sets to
people that are subscribed but we'll
talk about that later on in the video
now we haven't confirmed that the series
will drop on the 30th of march giving us
a six week break between book of boba
fett and its release throughout the
trailer we get the song day and night by
kid curry playing in the background and
steven talks about how he can't tell the
difference between his real life and his
dreaming one thus he has tied himself to
the bed and he locks himself in his
apartment even taping down the doors so
that he can't run a muck at night now
more recent comics have explored his
psyche a lot more and he's actually been
diagnosed with dissociative personality
disorder which this trailer seems to be
tackling at one point we see him playing
with a rubik's cube which could
symbolize all the aspects of his persona
rubik's cubes are made of different
colours that all twist and turn in order
to take prominence much like how
steven's personalities all over right
the other they all look different too
but when properly put in place they make
a hole instead of being fractured and
this series could be about him learning
to find balance with every side of
himself sleep is clearly playing a big
part and we even catch a sleep app on
his phone if you look carefully now this
is important because he says he can't
tell the difference between his waking
life in his sleeping one he of course
goes out at night as a vigilante and
likely swaps between the personalities
without even knowing he's doing it we
can catch him driving in a van at one
point and he looks shocked he has a gun
so i'm guessing this is mark out on a
mission that plays into his origin story
and then he swaps out as steven he also
finds his phone and key inside a
triangle cut hole which was likely left
by mark and triangles are of course the
shape that was used for the pyramids the
background on the phone also has a
crocodile which is possibly enough to
seback the ancient god of the nile now
there's heavy callbacks to ancient
egyptian myths and at one point we can
catch him in a museum with several
statues and idols around him this
includes the sun god raj osiris and also
anubis osiris is heavily associated with
mummification and we can catch a mummy
on the floor in the reflection of the
mirror steven leaves but there are two
reflections that we see which remain
behind and it is possible that these
represent the other facets of his
personality aka jake and mark mirrison
reflections play a big part in the
trailer and it's likely that these will
be used so they can basically do
enormous osborn and talk to the other
sides of his personality i think that
would explain why stephen is constantly
spouting off dialogue in the trailer
that makes it sound like he could be
talking to himself his voice shifts at
several points in the teaser making me
think that he's gonna have several
different variations there is of course
the cockney one for steven but mark is
american so it's going to be interesting
to see how they handle this whole thing
in the comics though he was known to
operate in america most of this teaser
appears to be set in london and it seems
like that's where the steven personality
resides at now in the disney plus day
trailer we could see him wearing what
appears to be the white suit and gloves
and this is likely the suit costume
instead of the more gritty vigilante one
however the main costume is what takes a
big focus in this teaser which too
appears in the reflections of mirrors i
absolutely love this reveal and it looks
so good normally marvel costumes are a
bit hit and miss for me but they've
really nailed this one and it looks
exactly how i'd want to see it in live
action we also see in one of the
reflection shots that he has a swollen
lump on his cheek potentially showing
that he got this when another one of his
personas was fighting and this one is
just finding out now there is also a
shot where he seems to snap out of
something and we see people bloodied
around his feet so it looks like he'll
be jumping back and forth between
personas and possibly doing this through
the use of mirrors now in the bathroom
scene we can also see that amir is
smashed here too potentially showing
that he's had enough and try to take
this out museums also play a big part in
this teaser and the character can be
seen in them throughout the entire thing
just before we travel into the bathroom
we can catch a museum flyer for ancient
egypt and he seems to spend a lot of
time in them now inside this bathroom we
can catch mark pummelling a creature and
i believe that this is actually a jackal
jackals play a prominent role in ancient
egyptian culture and though it could be
the god anubis i actually think that
it's one of his underlings when the
disney plus day trailer dropped a lot of
you pointed out that there was a spooky
dark figure that appeared to be stalking
him and i actually think that this is
the jackal that we see in the bathroom
scene and that all these moments will
tie together i believe that we will
likely get the scene in which he hides
before that moves to the car at a moment
which is when mark takes over steven
dons the moonlight costume and then
tackles the monster this costume appears
to wrap around him like the bandages of
the mummy and once more it's a further
call back to konshu akonshu does appear
in the trailer at one point and he
slowly walks towards mark as he hides in
an elevator he's scary as hell but
luckily he's an ally and he can catch
his hand that looks similar to a mummy
wrap before an old woman intervenes
thank you for saving me old lady you
don't know how scared i was now museums
also play a big part in the eternals and
not to get too deep into spoilers in
case you haven't seen it but its
post-credits scene does take place in
the london museum and there are teases
that a group is being formed potentially
moonai could be part of that as he's
worked alongside the black knight in
blade but we'll just have to wait and
see now it's not too long before we're
introduced to ethan hall who i think is
playing sun king this villain is a
pyrokinetic who too spent time in the
army and he was also committed to
ravencroft the insane asylum that you
might know from venom let there be
carnage the homie ryan area also pointed
out that sun king is somewhat the
opposite to moon knight so yeah i think
that would be a great first villain for
him to go up against he seems like a
cult leader who wants steven to embrace
chaos and we get cuts of moonlight's
time in egypt as well as him suiting up
in the bathroom and outside the teaser
ends with him beating up that jackal and
we get a full look at the suit which
just seems like it's incredible also i
got about 2 30 am to make this video
yeah i'm a bit tired so sorry if i'm not
that enthusiastic but i did really enjoy
it and the thumbs up are appreciated now
as for my thoughts on the trailer i'm
really excited to see what oscar isaac
is gonna do with the character i'm still
kind of a bit bummed out with how they
handle kingpin and i'm hoping that they
don't end up neutering moonlight just to
make him appeal to kids there's a lot of
things going on with the character such
as his dark past as a mercenary and also
the multiple personalities that he
possesses my biggest worry right now is
that frank castle is brought into the
mcu and that they call him the punisher
and just have him shooting balloon
animals oh that isn't the same thing
with moonlight but the trailer does look
like it's getting the tone of the
character right which is a step in the
right direction with stuff like this
it's always difficult to know whether
they're gonna nail it or not but it
doesn't really look like they're holding
back and the atmosphere of the show is
something that feels stark sinister and
also really weird but in a good way now
one thing i'm really not sure on though
is the accent sounds like dick van dyke
and mary poppins and i'm really hoping
that it's used for comedic effect as i
don't know anyone who talks like that
what you mean that's exactly how i talk
but yeah it looks great and obviously
i'd love to hear your thoughts on the
trailer so make sure you comment below
and let me know we are in a competition
right now and giving away three copies
of an mc boxer of your choice on the
30th of january and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the teaser
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now save
that to you then message me on twitter
at heavyspoilers if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our brighton of carla kai in which
we go over all the easter eggs call
backs and references to the karate kid
it's one of our best videos so hopefully
i see you over there after this and
sorry i sound a bit trained yeah it's
it's been a long week i've not really
stopped working anyway without the way
thanks for clicking this and thanks for
your support you're the best see you
next time bye